five senate republicans play the willing
suckers for joe biden's big
infrastructure plan
and biden continues to frighten everyone
with bizarre public performances as
kamala harris waits
in the wings literally i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first your reminder if you're
a responsible human
you need to make sure that your family
has life insurance against your life
god forbid you're walking down the
street get hit by a bus it's gonna be
terrible for your family on an emotional
level obviously but also they're going
to lose your stream of income you need
to make sure that doesn't happen
every responsible person with dependence
needs life insurance the best place to
get it at the best available price
policy genius because policy genius
helps you shop life insurance policies
competitively not just via word of mouth
or something policy genius makes it easy
to compare quotes from over a dozen top
insurers
all in one place why compare well you
could say 50
or more on life insurance by comparing
quotes with policy genius you could save
300 bucks or more per year on life
insurance by using policy genius to
compare policies
the licensed experts the policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process that kind of service has
earned policy genius an excellent rating
on trustpilot getting started super
simple first head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro again that's
www.policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
compare personalized quotes find
your best price head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro get started
right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and very important to get it
right okay so yesterday afternoon
joe biden came out and announced a deal
had been reached
on infrastructure yay okay so first of
all let me just note america's
infrastructure
is not in serious trouble the notion
that america's infrastructure
is just awful and bad in every way and
it's just horrifying
it's not true the vast majority of
america's roads and bridges are
pretty okay and the vast majority of the
ones that are really not doing well
are ones that are in particular states
which means they really should be state
costs
not federal costs like the notion that
we have much worse infrastructure than
anywhere else
on earth or that we really need to pour
like a trillion dollars minimum two
trillion dollars into infrastructure
is just not correct but this has become
sort of the go-to
whenever you are a member of government
and you just want to blow money
into things all you do is you just say
infrastructure because this is something
people
on a basic level understand right we all
sort of understand that the government
has a hand in building roads for example
because the roads connect all sorts of
different communities and so you want
the government
to shoulder the cost of what is in
effect a non-excludable non-rivalrous
good right we all sort of get that the
roads are
at the very least a public good right
something that government does
we we understand that the government
helping to foment the the placing of
broadband even is something that that
benefits a lot of americans although if
you just deregulate it the truth is a
lot of these companies can pay for it
themselves
but we all sort of get the idea that the
government should be involved to a
certain extent
in the infrastructure project because
public goods are typically
again non-excludable non-rival risk
goods
in which private people sometimes can't
agree
okay so does that mean that the federal
government needs to spend hundreds of
billions of dollars right now on this
stuff in the middle of a giant
inflationary spiral
in which we have a shortage of materials
and a shortage of labor of course not
of course not but this has become joe
biden's big bipartisan push because he
figures that if he can get
republicans on board for infrastructure
then he can pretend that he is a
bipartisan president when in fact he's
an extremely partisan president now they
already passed
fairly recently a bipartisan bill that
was supposed to
send a bunch of money toward quote
unquote research and development
directed at fighting against china and
it passed with wide bipartisan support
even though again it is a giant pork
bill so there's another giant pork bill
now republicans if they had any brands
be like nope
not interested right because the reality
is that
you aren't going to spend a lot more
money than we would like you to spend
and if you're going to do that you can
do that on your own
like truly if you just want to blow out
the deficit for no appreciable gain
then you can just do that on your own
right make you use reconciliation for it
if you want to break the filibuster and
you're going to have to do it through
the budget process because you only have
two or maybe three of those per year
waste a bullet on on this infrastructure
package
and let you own it but no we have to
have the quote-unquote moderate wing
of the republican party including people
like susan collins and mitt romney who
decide that it's important to lend
bipartisan cover to joe biden
now here's the thing they are being
played they're obviously
being played i'll explain how in just
one minute so
according to the new york times
president biden struck an infrastructure
deal on thursday with a bipartisan group
of senators signing on to their plan to
provide about 579 billion dollars in new
investments
in roads broadband internet electric
utilities and other projects
in hopes of moving a crucial crucial
piece of his economic agenda
through congress biden's endorsement
marked a breakthrough in his efforts to
forge an infrastructure compromise
but here's the thing it was far from a
guarantee the package would be enacted
both the president and top democrats say
the plan which constitutes a fraction
of the four trillion dollar economic
proposal biden has put forth can only
move together with a much larger package
of spending and tax increases democrats
are planning to try to push through
congress unilaterally
over the opposition of republicans so
here is what biden is doing
and this is why these republicans are
just adults what he's doing is he's
bifurcating this package
he's saying what if we pass this part
here with bipartisan support but
i'm only going to sign the bipartisan
part if
you guys allow me to vote on and sign
this giant other package that's the same
thing as just putting it all in the same
package
what are you talking about okay so in
other words he's going to get
pretty much what he wants and he's going
to get the veil of bipartisanship at the
same time so here is joe biden
announcing we have a deal we had a
really good meeting and answer your
direct question we have a deal
and uh i think it's really important
we've all agreed that
uh none of us got what we all were that
we wanted
i clearly didn't get all i wanted they
gave more than
i think maybe they were inclined to give
in the first place
but this reminds me of the days we used
to get an awful lot done up in the
united states congress
we actually worked we had bipartisan
deals
we got a bipartisan deal except they
didn't get a bipartisan deal as we'll
explain in just a minute now biden is
using this
he again to pretend that he is a
bipartisan president with wide public
support
he is not he's got a 52 public approval
rating right now
okay now that is pretty much the exact
same percentage of the popular vote that
he won
last time around right over the popular
vote he won like 51 52
he has not increased that he has not
decreased that it's a pretty hard
base of support but it's also a hard
level of support
on the ceiling so as things start to
accrue
you know as the crime rates continue to
remain high as the economy continues to
flounder more than it is soaring
as all of that happens he's likely to
feel some economic pain from
some sort of popular pain from that but
republicans are providing him a cover
for no appreciable gain it makes no
sense at all
here is biden however saying i'm not
going it alone i'm not doing i don't
have to go alone anymore
i know there are some of my party who
discouraged me from seeking an agreement
with our republican colleagues
who said that we should go bigger and go
alone
to them i say this i've already shown
in my young presidency that i'm prepared
to do whatever needs to get done to move
the country forward
that's what i did with the american
rescue plan which is 1.9 trillion
dollars let me say this
when we can't we can't find common
ground though working across party lines
that is what i will seek to do except
he's not looking for common ground as
we'll see
what he's looking for is the veil of
bipartisanship so he can ram through 95
of what he wants we'll get to that in
just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you
really don't want to go to the auto
parts store because he wants to go to
the auto parts store you're going to
stand in line for a while then finally
you'll get to the front of the line and
some attendant's going to ask you a
bunch of specific questions
you'll have to go back out look at your
car give them the answer and then he'll
be like oh yeah we don't have that
part in stock so would you like me to
order that online for you to arrive in
two weeks with an upcharge
or you could just go directly to the
internet and cut out all the middlemen
rockauto
they always offer the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear like
airlines do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same exact parts their family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers the catalog is
unique and remarkably easy to navigate
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle and choose
the brands
specifications and prices you prefer go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box
so they know that we sent you again
there really is no reason to go to an
auto parts store pretty much ever again
just go to rockauto.com right now and
get the parts you need
to make your auto move the way it is
supposed to rockauto.com right now right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
his box so they know that he was saying
okay so mitt romney playing the willing
duke
as per his usual arrangement here is the
senator from utah announcing how happy
is with this bipartisan compromise
one of the big surprises i had coming to
washington was the sense that
while everybody was fighting with each
other you know what we get along really
well this group gets along very well my
colleagues in the senate
we work together and it's been years and
years people have been talking about the
infrastructure needs of our country we
know that we recognize the crumbling
infrastructure and this group came
together and actually got a job done
oh my god look we got a job except you
didn't you didn't
quote from the new york times on capitol
hill democrats signaled their openness
to accepting the initial details of the
agreement
provided that their moderate colleagues
accept a second much larger
reconciliation package so in other words
we will definitely sign on to this
compromise package so long as you also
accept this giant pile of manure
that we've got right here for you that
we're gonna hit you in the face with it
really is an amazing thing
and so so and by the way this is joe
biden agreeing with this plan
right so joe biden's like we came to a
compromise and then with one hand he's
like here's the compromise with the
other hand
say and here right here what's in this
boom and he hits him with the other hand
not in a really strong punch there's not
a lot of
power behind joe biden's punches at this
point but at the same time i mean here
is joe biden saying
i support nancy pelosi's plan to hold
the bipartisan infrastructure bill
hostage
until the senate passes a big
reconciliation bill right here he is
saying
that i'm going to i'm not going to sign
this bill alone now normally when you
say i've reached a compromise with
somebody like you've ever done a
contract negotiation with somebody else
you do the contract negotiation you
finally come to some sort of agreement
everybody breaks out the wine and cigars
and you're lighting up and then if
somebody in the room says
oh yeah by the way i'm not signing that
unless you also sign this agreement that
pays me x
that's not an agreement okay so to
pretend this is an agreement a
triumphant moment of bipartisanship is a
lie here is joe biden
pretty much making the lie clear do you
support vanessa
pelosi's stated plan to hold the
bipartisan deal
in the house until the senate also
passes reconciliation do you support
that sequencing on her part
yes the bipartisan bill from the very
beginning was understood there's going
to have to be the second part of it
not just signing the bipartisan bill and
forgetting about the rest i
that i proposed i proposed a significant
piece of legislation in three parts
and all all three parts are equally
important okay so in other words
all three parts are equally important i
put all the stuff that republicans are
okay with in one part so we can pretend
they agree with it
and then i'm gonna ram through the other
two pieces of the agreement that they
don't agree with
right so pretty amazing stuff now here's
the reality joe biden is not the
president
of this particular process joe manchin
is the president of this particular
process so here is joe manchin the
senator from west virginia
who is signaling well i'm not so sure
about this whole nancy pelosi let's hold
the bill hostage idea
to say that one's being held hostage to
the other doesn't seem to be fair to me
but they're going to make those
decisions
but we have to see what's in the other
plan before i can say oh yes
you vote for this and i'll vote for that
that's not what i have signed up for
okay so maybe joe manchin doesn't go
along with what joe biden and nancy
pelosi are planning here
okay that's that's really the only hold
up maybe mitt romney and susan collins
maybe to their credit maybe they think
that they can rely on joe manchin to be
the man in the gap here and joe manchin
is going to be like no we're going to
pass this bipartisan compromise bill on
its own
and also i'm not going to kill the
filibuster or vote for this particular
bill if it
if the reconciliation project process is
used in order to ram it through
maybe they're counting on joe manchin
let me just say i don't think that that
is a particularly wise move instead it
looks much more like joe biden gets 99
of what he wants
plus he gets this patina of republican
of republican bipartisan
notions to go along with it so i'll
uphond it
over at hot air writes about he says if
the gop had managed to negotiate biden
down
to a much less expensive infrastructure
built with no tax hikes that might be a
worthy compromise but they haven't
there are two parts to the democrats
infrastructure plan one a bipartisan
bill that deals with roads and bridges
and the other
a party line reconciliation bill that
covers quote unquote human
infrastructure like climate change
spending paid leave and so on
spending that doesn't end up in the
bipartisan bill will likely just be
lateraled over to the reconciliation
bill
which means republicans aren't achieving
much in terms of spending essentially
they're pressing on one end of a water
balloon shrinking that end but causing
the other end to swell
as the water is displaced the volume of
the balloon is the same whether they're
pressing or not
it's purely a matter of distribution and
frankly if that's the case
maybe republicans should have done the
opposite of what they did arguing to put
more money into the true roads and
bridges infrastructure components
and thereby hopefully shrinking the
human infrastructure reconciliation bill
that would have been risky because
democrats could pass that human
infrastructure bill
irrespective of how big the true
infrastructure bill gets but maybe if
the latter were bigger
mansion would get nervous about blowout
spending and be more inclined to shrink
the other component
now biden and pelosi are both nervous
about being double crossed by mansion
who's been dogged about trying to
compromise with republicans
so today both the president and speaker
issued an ultimatum unless and until
both
bills pass the senate they won't even
move on the bipartisan bill
so basically saying imagine we're not
even going to vote in the house
on the bipartisan bill that joe biden
just endorsed until
you vote using reconciliation processes
for these other blowout spending bills
so essentially you're going to hold that
roads and bridges bill hostage
in order to make sure that manchin does
what they want on the giant spending
bill
well except here's the problem mansion
was asked about pelosi's strategy
he says there's going to be a
reconciliation bill we just don't know
what size it's going to be
manchin also said he was open to a
reconciliation bill that changes the
2017 gop tax law to raise taxes to pay
for new spending programs he said
reconciliation is inevitable because the
republican opposition to raising taxes
said he's open to it
he said if it's it's the only strategy
we have that's to track he says
reconciliation is inevitable
so maybe he's able to shrink it a little
bit
but maybe mansion again this just shows
you
that if joe manchin caucuses with the
democrats he's still a democrat
and so you can count on joe manchin for
one thing and one thing only and that is
not ending the filibuster
for non-reconciliation bills but for
reconciliation bills mainly
a reconciliation bill is defined as a
budget bill basically
for any budget bill which is spending in
taxation bill he will just go along with
the democrats
which means republicans got nothing here
it means
that depending on which way mansion goes
mitt romney and susan collins and the
rest of these jokers got played
so mansion is the obvious winner he now
gets to claim that he forged a
bipartisan deal
and biden gets to claim that he forged a
bipartisan deal republicans get nothing
republicans get get nothing okay so it's
just
it's an amazing failure by these
republicans like mitt romney again
there is a an aspect of conservatism
that is institutionalist
in in structure right this sort of the
john roberts constitutionalism in which
john roberts suggests that the key role
that he plays on the supreme court to
take an example of this sort of
conservatism
is to uphold the vigor and and the
durability of the institution and it
doesn't matter if i rule against the
constitution it doesn't matter if i have
to rewrite obamacare in order to make it
comply with the constitution
it doesn't matter if i am constantly
forging nine zero unanimous votes that
are far smaller
in scope in protecting american rights
than a 63 majority decision would be
john roberts has upheld the institution
and you get the same thing here
from mitt romney now there is something
to upholding the institution right you
want to uphold the institution of the
filibuster even when you're in control
this is what mitch mcconnell was saying
he was saying if you get rid of the
filibuster here
then when democrats take control you're
really going to regret it and i think
he's right about that
but what mitt romney is doing is beyond
that what romney and collins are doing
is they're saying it is so important
that the american people think that we
can forge compromise here
that i will i will provide the lie that
compromise was actually had here even
when it wasn't
so that you think the american people
that the senate can work
now here's the thing when it comes to
actual popular policy
the senate does actually vote
overwhelmingly
you'll remember that just last week the
senate voted 100 nothing to make
juneteenth the national holiday for
example you'll remember that again there
was a bipartisan bill that went forward
to spend some hundreds of billions of
dollars on research and development
supposedly
they're basically going to be just
subsidies to particular friends of the
government
to to fight chinese innovation right so
it's not that bipartisanship is dead
it's that you have to be a not but
unfortunately
there are too many republicans who want
to appear back home like i understand
susan collins i really do susan collins
from maine
right maine is a purple a purple to blue
state i understand why susan collins is
doing it mitt romney is from the reddest
state in america outside of west
virginia utah is an extremely red state
there is no reason why mitt romney has
to sign on to a bill like this mike lee
isn't he's from the same exact state
there's no reason why mitt romney feels
he should have to forge
compromise in this way but for some
reason again this goes to mitt romney's
perception of himself and so much of
politics
really is how politicians perceive
themselves mitt romney perceives himself
as a as a deal maker
and a person who brings people together
in the same way that john mccain used to
perceive himself
this way right you want to be part of
that gang of eight or that gang of ten
or that gang of four whatever the gang
is because this means you're a very
important person a person who gets
things done
what if the goal of checks and balances
is to prevent things from getting done
however
what if we need to completely shift our
mindset with regard to why are we
bothering to get things done if they are
bad things
and let's face it in the end what joe
biden is relying on to do what he wants
to do here
is the the basic fist
inside the velvet glove which is the
possibility of just killing the
filibuster altogether
right is that joe biden is figuring that
at a certain point
mansion is going to cave one way or
another or cinema is going to cave one
way or another
or maybe if he can just cast to get
republicans enough they'll kill the
filibuster bill clinton
i mean it's amazing how far the
democratic party has moved bill
clinton's presidency
was successful entirely because of
bipartisan compromise
bill clinton's first couple of years he
had a democratic congress and he was an
awful failure
he tried to pass hillary care it bombed
he raised capital gains taxes
he reigns he raised income taxes and by
republicans had won back congress for
the first time in like 30 years
so bill clinton's rest of his presidency
was negotiating with newt gingrich
in order to do things for the american
people like welfare reform like a 1994
crime bill
that actually were effective on behalf
of the american people
right this is and now you have bill
clinton and he has revised his opinion
now the filibuster must be murdered
i understand the president's reluctant
to get rid of it all together
and i'm sympathize with joe manchin
who's trying to
you know stand up for the right thing
and represent people that voted
more than two to one for president trump
but i think when it comes to preserving
democracy
you know i would suspend the filibuster
because i think it's essential i don't
think
that we should be in the business of
going backwards
in trying to drive down voting rights i
think we need to expand it
okay so again in the end it's pure power
politics for these democrats who don't
fall for the bipartisan trap
it's it is it remains a source of
amazement to me
that so many republicans are willing to
fall for this sort of stuff
the the romney's getting played colin's
getting played and they're getting
nothing out of this they're getting
nothing out of this
now meanwhile all they really have to do
is just stand there that's all they have
to do
because joe biden is not with us hey joe
biden is not a strong president he is in
fact a very weak president
what he is capable of getting done under
these circumstances are
it's very limited maybe because let's
face it joe manchin is not upholding the
filibuster because he's a nice guy joe
manchin is upholding the filibuster
because he is a blue state senator
from a red state because he is a
democrat in a state that
that donald trump won by i believe 39
points in the last election cycle
kristen cinema is not i think
congenitally predisposed to loving the
filibuster
just recognizes that she's got john
mccain's old seat basically in arizona a
very purple state
with a with a red governor and a and a
red legislature
and so she i think properly and
understandably
knows where her bread is buttered so
with that said
joe biden can't get a lot done here so
why are republicans helping him to get
things done here
why he's going to do it anyway make him
own it
if he's going to do it anyway make him
own it i don't understand for the life
of me
what mitt romney and susan collins think
that the republican party broadly
speaking gets out of it now
the reality is that this because of the
democrat trying to the democrats trying
to link these two things that they're
only going to vote on the bipartisan
deal
if they also get to ram through this
reconciliation bill because of that
i think that this thing will probably
get filibustered anyway remember you
need 60 votes to overcome the filibuster
getting five republicans ain't enough
you need 10 republicans
to kill the filibuster where are they
gonna get those other five republicans
who go forward with the vote on the
bipartisan infrastructure
plan if they're simultaneously linking
it
with a piece of legislation that they're
going to ram through in a 50 50 vote
with one extra ding from from kamala
harris who is sitting as the
as the presiding officer in the senate
so
i think all the talk about
bipartisanship is a little bit too early
i don't think this is going to actually
go to a bipartisan vote
on this particular bill and i and you
watch the media will then call the
republicans obstructionist
they'll then say it's the republicans
fault so republicans lose on both ends
they give joe biden the veneer a
bipartisanship and then
they themselves are called partisan when
they obstruct the bill because it turns
out that joe biden has already linked it
to another bill that is in fact not
bipartisan
that is the stupid play stupid games win
stupid prizes for the republican party
okay in just a second
we're going to get to our non-sentient
presidents and kamala harris waiting
in the wings first let us talk about the
fact that you
as a company constantly need better
employees you do you need great
employees if you're a business owner
who's hiring you probably face a lot of
challenges when it comes to finding the
right person for your role that's why
hiring can feel like trying to find a
needle in a haystack sure you could post
your job to some job board then all you
can do is hope the right person comes
along which is why you should try zip
recruiter for free
at zip recruiter.com dailywire when you
post a job on ziprecruiter it gets sent
out to over 100 at top job sites with
just one click then
zip recruiter their matching technology
will find people with the right skills
and experience for your job and actively
invite them to apply
in fact zip recruiters so effective four
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
day one it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for
their hiring needs so while other
companies are going to overwhelm you
with way too many options
zip recruiter helps you find the diamond
in the rough
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at this web address
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire once again remember go to this
uniqueplace ziprecruiter.com
w i r d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e z recruiter is
indeed the smartest way to hire okay
meanwhile
joe biden just i i don't know what to
say about this anymore other than joe
biden
is he's a crazy person guys he's a crazy
person he's adult
he's not with us he's crazy there's a
reason why you don't see clips
regularly of joe biden being played in
the media instead they'll sort of print
what he says right you see it in the
print
but you'll never see these clips
circulating anywhere but sort of oppo
sources right you'll see it you'll hear
it on my show you'll see it on fox news
you're never going to see this clip of
joe biden blasted out
i mean this is a live press conference
so they sort of got it but you're not
going to see it repeated
okay so this is a live press conference
yesterday at the white house
and uh and here's the president of the
united states
being like this is so weird he's just a
weird old dude man i mean like this is
all right here we go i got them
1.9 trillion dollars relief so far
they're going to be getting checks in
the mail that are consequential
this week i wrote the bill
on the environment pay them more
this is an employee's
employees bargaining chip now
what's happening um okay put aside what
he's saying which is
insanely stupid right but i mean what
he's actually saying
there is that if you want people to come
back to work you have to pay them more
because the government is paying them to
stay home and somehow this is good for
the economy
and then he says inflation is not the
predictable result which is stupid okay
so put aside the content
why is he channeling the clown from it i
just don't understand
why because he's not with us gang
because he's a weird
old man he's like georgie
would you like your boat back it's worth
1.9 trillion dollar
pay your employees more georgie come
down and here's a balloon
f is going what i'm i'll be honest
that's like if you have nightmares at
night about monsters hiding under your
bed
that's the voice right there that that's
what's going on
okay and then he just says like adult
things all the time
he just says adult things all the time
so he he was asked
so he finishes a press conference
yesterday and there's this horrifying
situation
in surf side florida and and our prayers
go out
to the the folks over in surf side
there's been this this
horrifying condo collapse in in
surf side like half the building
collapsed it appears
likely that there were structural
defects in the building that were
revealed over time as maybe the building
was sinking into the ground because
it was built on the beach very scary
stuff 100 people missing
really tragic and and by the way just
gonna put this out there for for folks
who do want to give
there is a there is a website that has
been set up
by one of the big synagogues over there
where you can give money to help out the
families of the
of the people who are suffering uh it's
at uh i'll give you the website it's a
thejessedfund.com
v-c-h-e-s-e-d-f-u-n-d.com
shul of bell ball harbor
s-h-u-l-o-f-b-a-l-h-a-r-b-o-u-r
slash miami tragedy and it's a long web
address but they're trying to raise like
a million bucks for for the people
who are suffering from that tragedy in
any case joe biden finishes his press
conference yesterday
and he just um starts wandering out of
the room
and kamala harris has to remind him that
this thing happened and he's just like
oh my gosh
it's so awkward here we go
will you travel to florida sir can we
ask you about florida what you've
learned and what oh
yes i apologize yes thank you my
president
okay and he just starts laughing at
himself and forget it it's just it's so
awkward to watch he's still
my president right he's your president
too it's it's um it is awkward to watch
i mean just a couple of days ago it's
written to nuke americans so there was
there's that
he also said yesterday that if he had
his way there would be no private
contributions to campaigns at all all
campaigns would be publicly funded
what in the act what what
okay here we go there's a lot of
ancillary pieces of this legislation
i strongly support i strongly support
the idea that there's no
there's no uh pri provide my way there'd
be no private contributions to see who
gets elected
uh how much money you raise no private
contributions
to political candidates okay what are
you talking about there is the supposed
voting rights bill
that sets up public funding for
candidates so your taxpayer dollars
should go to joe biden
to run for office this is what he would
prefer that's good
also he's been using the term latinx
which is a good indicator that you've
never met a latino or latina person
because there's not a single latino
person on planet earth calls themselves
latinx it's only a bunch of upper crust
white idiots
who took critical race theory studies
who who think that latinx is an actual
term
that is used by the way you know the
origin of latinx right
latin x is because is because spanish is
a gendered language
okay and latinos for males and latina is
for females and so we wouldn't want to
say latino
because we wouldn't want to say latinos
because that inevitably
includes women what so instead they set
up latin acts that's the stupidest thing
i've ever heard it's unbelievably dumb
okay hebrew is also a gendered language
right when you say for example people
the word in hebrew for for people is an
ashim
okay the the suffix in english would be
y
m but it's you'd mem the suffix eem is
for males but it includes females
just as when in english you say human it
includes the word man and now woman
and when you say mankind includes man
but it includes women
so now we are going to do this with
foreign languages this is the stupidest
thing i've
he here he is being an idiot there's a
reason why
it's been harder to get
african-americans initially
to get vaccinated because they're used
to being experimented on
the tuskegee airmen and others
people have memories people have long
memories
it's awful hard as well to get
latinx vaccinated as well why
they're worried that they'll be
vaccinated and deported
that um what okay so first of all what
he's saying there
right there is that the um the
um hmm what he is saying there is like
racist
right he's saying that the reason that
the latino people are not getting
vaccinated is because they're all afraid
they're gonna get supported
now 18 of the american population is
latino i'm fairly certain the vast
majority of those people
are not illegal immigrants are not
afraid of being deported so no
on that and also i failed to understand
how it is good logic
that because between 1932 and 1972
there were tuskegee experiments racist
experiments that were conducted
to that allowed essentially the the
syphilis to grow in black people to see
how
it was going to affect their minds i
failed to see how an experiment that was
first conducted
in 1932 is a good excuse for not getting
a vaccine in 2021
nonetheless the um it's
it's weird it's it's a weird thing also
i
like how he calls it the tuskegee airmen
experiment uh
no that no those are two separate things
those are two separate things
okay the tuskegee experiment was a cruel
and vicious racist policy
tuskegee airmen were the black men who
flew
in jet fighters who flew in fighters
during
world war ii not the same thing he's not
with us well the good news is that we at
least have kamala harris waiting in the
wings
literally in the wings so yesterday
during this bipartisan
press conference things got really
really awkward we'll get to that in just
one second first you need to keep your
family safe and secure and a lot of us
have guns right we all believe in the
second amendment around here but it's
not just having a gun it's also
being able to protect yourself using
things like body armor that is really
really
important well this is why you need ar
500 armor they've got loadouts designed
for everyone whether you need a
concealable vest for daily use a plate
carrier for the range or a fully
equipped setup for the worst case
scenario
our friends at ar500 armor have made
buying body armor easy approachable and
affordable if you're unsure what type of
armor you need
or you just need some pointers based on
your needs they have you covered air 500
armor has multiple packages pre-built
for people just like you
simplifies the entire process of
purchasing armor they have their
independence day sale going on right now
you can have your order before the
fourth of july
these sales are up to 50 off select
products so go get them while they last
they have rifle rated bundles starting
as low as 99 bucks they also share your
values i know the folks at r500 armor
these are people who care about the
constitution they care about the
declaration and they care about your
second amendment rights and ability to
protect yourself
text ben to 88027 to see all their
promotions and special pricing
running right now you can use code ben
for 20 off anything in their entire
store best of all they put together some
packages specifically for my listeners
so there's something for everyone at
ar500armor.com
again text ben to 88027 for 20
off your very first order already so
meanwhile yeah kamala harris waiting in
the wings which is not
if you thought that it was creepy when
joe biden was whispering at you just a
few moments ago
how creepy is it what was going on in
the background of this particular
bipartisan photo so yeah joe biden
kristen cinema by the way i just have to
compliment kristin's cinema's sense of
style
like it actually is kind of fabulous i
am not a i'm not a fashion
a fashion reviewer although i will say
that i found it very odd and still find
it odd that nancy pelosi has a face mask
to match every outfit but kristen cinema
really brings it right i mean like
that's pretty cool outfit i kind of like
that is a kristen cinema uh
shows up wearing like this this red
thing and it's it's cool okay and you've
got this entire bipartisan group of
senators
and then lurking in the background
there's something happening behind mitt
romney's shoulder
there's a white pillar and then behind
that pillar in front of the white house
someone is waiting someone
is watching
my god
[Music]
oh man uh ain't that just a metaphor for
what's happening in the country right
now
kamala harris just waiting off to the
side waiting waiting
hmm man worst job in america joe biden's
food taster
do not walk down a set of stairs with uh
with kamala harris if you're joe biden
that is for day i'm sure by the way if
you're coming here you've got to be
pissed at this point right
because joe biden has basically put you
in charge of all the most popular parts
of his agenda unpopular parts of his
agenda so joe biden's like
you know come on why don't you like do
the border thing
uh and we won't change any of our our
policies but you're in charge now
and then she's like
and um she doesn't go down by the way
she's headed down to the border all it
took was donald trump saying he was
headed to the border
and then she's rushing down to the
border as fast as her feet
can carry her feet don't fail her now so
good things happening over in the biden
harris
administration this is why guys if
you're republicans why are you providing
them cover
make them own it first rule of politics
do not stop your opponents when they are
making mistakes
but again everyone in politics
apparently is stupid and meanwhile
the democrats continue to double down on
the trump of it all
because here is the thing without trump
their policies become the issue in 2022
and 2024. so we're going to continue
to focus in on january 6th now no one
on the right was harsher on january 6th
than i was i thought a bunch of idiots
and droogs for
no not only no reason for
counter-productive purposes assaulting
the center of our legislative branch
attempting to do active physical harm to
legislators
i said all those people should be
arrested and they should be prosecuted
for having violated the law
okay if you commit a crime you get
arrested you get prosecuted i hold that
standard whether you are rioting and
looting in kenosha wisconsin or whether
you're doing it in the halls of congress
okay but the notion that this is some
sort of cataclysmic occurrence that
requires
a much deeper look at the heart of
america
well not by congress nancy pelosi
however is launching
a select committee the reason that she's
announcing the select committee is
because what she hopes
is that when you get to your 2022 ballot
you think of january 6th
as opposed to all the crappy policy that
the democrats are pushing they don't
want you to be thinking
about critical race theory they don't
want you to be thinking about their
subjugation of the police and
destruction of law and order in our
cities
they don't want you to be thinking about
inflation they don't want you to be
thinking about slow job growth or your
inability to hire workers or higher
prices at the supermarket they don't
want you to think about any of that they
want you to be thinking
solely and completely about donald trump
because donald trump is the worst person
ever to walk the earth so here is nancy
pelosi announcing a select committee now
here's the thing what do we have to find
out in the select committee
really we already have a senate
committee that did a full investigation
into the security failures and that
really is the story because it turns out
there are lots of people all over the
united states who in small groups
believe unbelievably stupid and
dangerous things
it's a country of 330 million people in
fact it would be pretty difficult to
find a single stupid
idiotic insane cause for which you could
not rally a couple of thousand people
in the united states because again 330
million people it's a lot of people with
the internet not hard for those people
to get together
but the real goal here for the democrats
of course is to suggest that january 6
was a natural outgrowth
of conservatism and right-wing thought
now there is a certain irony to the fact
that the democrats who full-scale
embrace
emperor max kennedy and full-scale
embrace robin deangelo and full-scale
embrace kimberly crenshaw
they say the critical race theory has
nothing to do with the indoctrination
into wokeness
of your nation's school children right
these are these are
distinct fields of thought but
january 6th is indicative of the entire
right-wing mindset in the united states
that's the whole goal of this the whole
goal of this is just to
carry out this investigation for as long
as possible try and lump everybody in
with january 6 i don't think it's going
to work out for the democrats really
i don't but here's nancy pelosi
announcing it anyway
this morning with great solemnity and
sadness
nope i'm announcing that the house will
be establishing
an uh select committee on the january
6th
insurrection again january 6
was one of the darkest days in our
nation's history i've said it now three
times
it is imperative that we establish the
truth of that day
and ensure that an attack of that kind
cannot happen and that we root
out the causes of it all okay um you
know what one of the causes was
the fact that the capitol police weren't
properly staffed up wait who's in charge
of the capitol police
again interesting okay so in just one
second
we'll get to what nancy pelosi is
actually doing with the select committee
of course which is to try and connect
january 6 with a broader ideology
because again democrats have to
misdirect it's all sleight of hand at
this point we'll get to that in just one
second first let me tell you
about like an amazing amazing gift so
all over my house at this point i have
beautiful photos of my family
created through my photo okay
myphoto.com is just fantastic here is
how it works you take
special photos and then you just kind of
leave them on your phone typically how
about instead of doing that you go over
to myphoto.com it is awesome it is easy
to use it takes two minutes to create a
special product for your own wall or
shelf
and make great gifts for your loved ones
my photo will print your image directly
on acrylic
glass metal more i mean it like it makes
a great birthday gift
my wife actually just did this for me
for father's day she's printed out a
bunch of photos from my photo we now
have a photo wall of our kids and it's
just gorgeous it's beautiful i love it
you need to go to myphoto.com and check
it out right now that is myphoto.com you
can order today you'll get 20
off your order which will arrive in just
five days prices start at just 12 bucks
use code ben get 20 off today it really
is fantastic
these photos look just beautiful because
again they're in acrylic
the ones that we have and so they really
they take in the light and they really
kind of shine it's really just gorgeous
stuff go to myphoto.com check it out
right now order today get 20
off your order it'll arrive in just five
days prices start at just 12 bucks by
the way i know the founders of the
company
wonderful wonderful people go check them
out right now myphoto.com and use code
ben to get 20
off today alrighty before we go any
further
we have an extremely interesting episode
coming out of the sunday special i'm
excited to share it with you
i'm joined by actor author host of the
under the skin podcast russell brand we
discuss everything from philosophy to
politics to spirituality
and his own tumultuous experience with
addiction it was a fantastic fascinating
conversation russell is a really
intriguing and interesting guy
it's out this sunday for your listening
pleasure here is a sneak peek
i want us in this time of division and
and fragmentation and fracture to find
ways of coming together
in peace coming together with peace
that's why i'm chatting to candice owens
and chat to you i don't want to sit
around chatting people i agree with
i want to talk to people where there are
areas of concern and discontent and
downright disagreement and find ways
that we can
harmonize
see these are really i think productive
and interesting conversation so i just
agree with russell on a lot of stuff
politically and we try to get sort of at
the roots of that and why that is and
identify where we agree and disagree i
think you're gonna love it it really is
fascinating go check it out this sunday
at dailywire.com or
on my youtube channel ben shapiro
dailywire members get access to special
bonus content from sunday special
episodes
do not miss out join daily wire today
also
if you enjoy your history unsensor you
need to make sure you are a daily wire
member
right now why because the daily wire is
now streaming
created equal it's the story of supreme
court justice clarence thomas
and his journey from humble beginnings
in the segregated south to the highest
court in the land
which by the way is the second black
american to ever do the documentary is
only available to daily wire members if
you want more stories that diverge from
the accepted political narrative go to
dailywire.com
subscribe get 20 off your new membership
with code
justice now here's the thing we need
your support for this kind of stuff
because
here documentaries like this one about
clarence thomas amazon like disappeared
it
during black history month they were
like you know what it's just gone poof
it's gone well we grabbed it up in order
for us to make that available to you we
need your support through your
subscriptions
justice thomas is in my view one of the
two greatest
political thinkers in america it's like
thomas soul and justice thomas and those
are the two
created equal is a wonderful documentary
in which he speaks direct to camera
about his own life
you can gain access it's great for your
kids to watch also because it really is
about the american dream
dailywire.com right now dailywire.com
subscribe and with co-justice you get 20
off your membership we need your support
and we really appreciate
your support also once you're a member
you get all of our great stuff right you
get our talk show candace featuring
candace owens or our first film run hide
fight or my new series debunked where i
debunk leftist myths in 15 minutes or
less which is a beautiful series it
looks great
and get all of that and more on demand
by going to dailywire.com
subscribe check out with 20 off using
code justice don't wait
start streaming today you're listening
to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
meanwhile look nancy pelosi when she's
pushing this senate select
this house select committee rather on
january 6 we know what it's really all
about right it's not about getting to
the bottom of the security failures
it's not about actually trying to fix
the problem what it really is about is
trying to pin
the droogs of january 6th on everybody
and so we just end up with mad libs like
left wing mad libs so here is nancy
pelosi trying to explain the origins of
january 6th
with reference to her favorite mush
words
there are two actual uh
paths one is about the
root causes of it the white supremacy
the anti-semitism the islamophobia
all the rest of it that was so evident
when you see a sweatshirt on one of the
people saying
camp auschwitz the other
is the security of the capital
and what what it means to be ready
for such an insurrection it's about
white supremacy and anti-semitism and
islamophobia
hey there were people in the building
who were anti-semitic she mentions one
guy who's a white supremacist
i'm sure there white supremacists in the
building january 6th generally speaking
as far as i'm aware has not been
explicitly linked to for example
islamophobia my last
the last i checked what january 6th
was about was people who thought that
the election was fraudulent and wanted
to stop the certification of the
election
i'm pretty sure if you're looking for
like the approximate cause it is that
like ideologically it's pretty specific
okay and there's plenty to indict people
for on that score with regard to
rhetoric
but you can't just stop there instead
it's all things
it's all the things because this is what
democrats do you see all of their
opponents are the worst people in the
world
it is not just that the people who
invaded the capitol building are bad
people or did a bad thing
it is that everybody who's associated
with a political cause that nancy pelosi
doesn't like
is in league with those people and you
can see democrats do this all the time
so the most predictable move
in american politics really was and i
predicted it openly on november 6th
and on january 20th i said as soon as it
becomes clear that there's another
republican
in the republican party who may win the
2024 nomination
if trump doesn't run or even if trump
does run and he just doesn't have the
steam that he had and in 2020 and
many republicans decide you know like
the guy but we want to move on
as soon as that happens as soon as there
appears to be any sort of heir
appearance of the republican nomination
that person will become worse than
hitler i.e worse than trump my most
predictable move
in american public life because it's
happened every single time right george
w bush
was i mean he is even worse than ronald
reagan just the worst i mean just
absolutely the worst remember the good
old days of like
georgia h.w bush george w so much worse
than his dad
and hw so much worse than reagan and
reagan's so much worse than nixon okay
and then
donald trump is so much worse than bush
in every way
he's worse than everyone and now donald
trump literally hitler
it turns out that ron desantis is even
worse than donald trump and there are
people who are skeptical of this they're
like no
the left won't do this i mean they hate
donald trump so much probably
and here's the thing donald trump used
to make the point
repeatedly still does on occasion that
it's not that the left
hates donald trump hate you because you
like trump
right no it's that they hate trump
because trump likes you
okay they hate trump because they hate
you and you can replace trump with
another figure and they will hit you
just as much all they will do is they
will start downplaying
trump in order to play up the idea that
whoever succeeds
inside the republican party is worse
than trump they even did this in 2016
frankly there were a bunch of people
like jonathan chait who were like oh
well you know
marco rubio and ted cruz are way worse
than trump okay guys
be careful what you wish for so now you
have samantha bee who honest to god
there was a running gun battle for like
least funny comedienne for a long time
and it's still going right stephen
colbert
is just not funny anymore he hasn't been
funny for years he basically just exists
as a democratic prop
and you have jimmy kimmel who again used
to be funny and is not anymore you got
trevor noah out there
but i think the person who easily takes
the cake is samantha who's not even
trying at this point
there's a phenomenon in the comedy world
that is now known as clapter where
instead of people laughing at your
supposed jokes they just clap
because they agree with you which
normally would just call like a
political speech
how samantha bee's writers get paid to
write
for her is beyond me i don't understand
i
i there are certain things in life i
just don't understand how samantha bee
is a fully employed human and
people find for entertaining apparently
like a very small subset of the
population
uh is beyond me so she did an entire hit
on ron desantis and of course the
premise of the hit was wait for it wait
for it
worse than trump that wasn't the most
predictable move ever because again
it's not about trump it's about you they
hate you you like desantis therefore
desantis is bad
they hate you if you like a company like
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a is bad
they hate you it was never about trump
it's not about desantis
it's about you samantha b sustains you
and if you like
rhonda sanchez and you think he's a good
governor which by the way he's an
excellent governor he's the best
governor in the country
if you like rhonda sanchez and how he's
handled florida it's because you are a
bad person
because ron desantis is hitler he's even
worse than trump according to samantha b
desantis was also one of the first
governors to attempt removing critical
race theory from his state's education
system
and last month he signed a restrictive
voting rights law that racially
discriminates against black and latino
voters
of course desantis is doing whatever he
can to pass racist laws he's racist
he's accepted money from a rich tapestry
of racist
refused to return their donations and
after president biden dared to talk
about systemic racism
desantis couldn't wait to share his own
nuanced opinion
this proposition that we are a
systemically racist country
your reaction well it's a bunch of horse
manure
ron desantis is so racist he refers to
separating his white laundry from his
colors as segregation
okay that's the joke well i'm um
what no i mean somebody got paid to
write that joke
understand that she she's provided no
evidence that rhonda sances is actually
racist
if you actually parse what she is saying
there at no point does she actually
provide any hard evidence these are just
a bunch of scoreless slurs
but that's not the point the point is
really not about the census the point is
about you
nancy pelosi the rest of the democratic
party they think that you're a bad
person they think that you're a bad
person and whoever you support
becomes even worse than the person that
you supported before because
your party is moving in only one
direction so here's my question to the
quote unquote moderates in the
republican party who want to cut
bipartisan deals with these folks
why why not just let them own it just
let them own it like really try to paint
ron de santa says quote-unquote worse
than trump and see how that works out
for you keep calling every republican
and every american who opposes critical
race theory or racist see how that works
out for you
it's a bold move cotton and i very much
look forward to seeing democrats reap
the whirlwind so long as republicans
stand out of the way and let them do it
alrighty folks we'll be back here later
today with an additional
hour of content in the meantime go check
out the andrew clavin show and conclude
your week with something magical drew's
show is every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you head on
over to dailywire.com
at 7 pm eastern 6 pm central tune in i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin